dans la ville libérée la parole elle
aussi se libère et si on a vu beaucoup
de gens être en larmes exposées en
larmes de joie et bien on a aussi croisé
beaucoup de larmes de tristesse j'ai pu
parler avec une habitante qui s'appelle
Liliana et qui en larmes m'a montré une
dizaine de trousseaux de clés dans ses
mains c'était les clés des appartements
de ses amis qui qui sont morts c'est
derrière ces derniers mois donc à Carson
le soulagement se mêle à un deuil
vraiment difficile certains habitants
nous ont raconté l'atmosphère
terrifiante qui régnait dans la rue ou
les gens n'osaient pas sortir de chez
eux parce que les soldats russes
fouillaient constamment les téléphones
des habitants afin de trouver la moindre
trace d'un d'un soutien à l'armée
ukrainienne on nous a parlé de cas de
torture de viol ou bien de de violences
physiques de la part des soldats russes
sur des jeunes hommes dans la rue sans
raison sans raison apparente donc six
personnes n'est peut-être libéré mais
elle reste en tout cas très meurtr et
des enquêtes sont en cours afin de faire
le point sur les crimes de guerre commis
par les commis par les troupes russes